[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur c'est autre chose
il est drôle
le futur de mademoiselle monsieur à la
taïga rade où ils passent tous les
matins une heure et demie à sa toilette
ses ongles surtout du printemps il est
proche il ratisse il a atteint 2 petit
instrument
il s'en sert comme de la bijouterie
c'est curieux à voir je ne sais pas si
c'est par là qu'il a séduite monsieur
type odier toujours est il que la bonne
âme s'est laissé prendre comme en fait
il se laisse prendre par tout le monde
c'est incroyable
un homme de son âge pas plus de défenses
qu'un enfant une timidité il ne jamais
dire non à quelle différence avec sa
fille voilà une petite tête qui avec son
petit air doux ne fait que ce qui lui
plaît je l'entends elle revient de sa
promenade du matin avec une petite botte
de fleurs dans son panier oui mais
va-t-elle à chauny
didot mademoiselle il se lève je viens
de lui porter son eau chaude à qui je
suis garé ado sait bien qu est ce que ça
me fait avec marc et ses ongles non
comment vous n'avez pas remarqué ses
ongles ils sont l'eau comme ça mais
l'autre jour en rouleaux rire la fenêtre
il en a cassé un fois la grand malheur
moi je suis bien que ça repousse mais
lui l'a parfaitement contrarié car
depuis ce mec me sens toujours pour
ouvrir la fenêtre je t'ai déjà prié de
ne pas me parler sans cesse de monsieur
radio slave et désagréable ça m'agace
or votre futur recrutement futur
à bas le mariage s'est pas encore fait
oui mon cher monsieur thibaudier il est
dans son cabinet depuis plus d'une heure
avec un particulier venu de paris de
paris
un jeune homme à chaque avocat bras
lerdou médinois non celui avez-vous avec
une grosse moustache
je crois que c'est un commis voyageur en
vain monsieur ne voulait pas de recevoir
un mail à presque forcé la porte avec
ces viols lors pourquoi papa de l'homme
en vaut-il monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà des échantillons je ne vais pas
besoin alors j'en ai pris quatre pièces
vous avez acheté la wii ne vous droguez
rivière et je sais bien mais le moyen de
refuser à monsieur bien me qui a fait
quatre lieux de paris à chatou pour
offrir sa marchandise après tout il est
dérangé ce thème là c'est vous qui la
dérangeait il divo way son vin le goûter
voyons la structure dit ça parce que tu
en penses à cette image est simple et
oui je me suis même permis de lui dire
avec ménagement
votre homme paraît un peu jeune j'ai cru
qu'il allait se passer
alors j'en ai pris quatre pièces ça
c'est mes cigares a dit qu'il n'avait
pas encore le vîmes ce garage ou non
tous les soirs il s'empare de mon
journal dès qu'il arrive il monte dans
sa chambre il vit pour s'endormir tu es
bien et vous mais moi je le lis l'homme
la bourse en prime un peu haut
si tu pouvais lui en toucher un mot non
semble salaire de venir de moins
soyez tranquille je l' ai pas marre est
vrai tueur se rassurent j'admire ton
assurance à 18 ans web
c'est plus fort que moi la présidence
d'un étranger dans ma maison ça me
trouve tamanu 1
mais de ça va bientôt finir ça dieu
merci à toutes ses demandes
ces présentations que vous tuez à oued
six mois c'est épouvantable le seul fait
non pas de me dire que je n'ai recevoir
quelqu'un ouais ça me fait peur
moi j'ai passé ma vie dans un bureau à
l'administration des archives des
archives secrètes encore alors forcément
recevait personnes samalut voilà
pourquoi j'aime pas à causer avec les
gens que je connais pas mais vous
connaissez donc beaucoup mais gare à
deux pas du tout
ah non ça il m'a été recommandé par mon
hôtel tout ce qu'on n'est pas non plus
non non non il s'est présenté à moi
tellement ça vont poser pendant deux
heures sans que je me la pète de dire
quatrevaux il veut dire et demande une
réponse
moi ça va vite tout de suite à mon aise
alors après il m'a demandé tu as main et
vous y avez accordé il paraît il paraît
que je lui ai accordé parce qu'il m'a
dit viens je veux belle carrière
alors aujourd'hui même il va venir et
nous allons faire à la mairie
les publications aujourd'hui bien 11h10
est lui qui a décidé ça un mois je me
mets dedans mais pas les skieurs et s'il
vous plaît beaucoup mais gare à toi tu
c'est un garçon charmant quelle facilité
par ans il est veuf j'admets que j'ai un
peu mais lui coûte 6 1 d'autres
prétendent ils se présentaient l otan
prétendent hui encore des manques du
président ta faudra tout recommencer
non je parle n'est pas un étranger
vous savez quoi monsieur gilles
frémissent à un avocat
bon je pourrais jamais le neveu je ne
connais pas moi je croyais y en a marre
a décrit ya trois mois avant d'art à 12
de ton projet mais justin n'a jamais
paru si tu n'as jamais pensé à toi c'est
papa jean celui-ci nous tentons lucio ne
parle pas franchement qu'est ce qu'il se
passait rien
il ne m'a jamais parlé eh ben mais les
jours de ce grand dîner que ma tante a
donné pour sa fête et vous n'allez pas
vous l'événement oui j'aime pas les
réunions quand il ya du monde
c'était pas un pas deux finissants oui
il rougit c'est qu'il ne faisait que
dégoût suivant jetant le sang revoilà
lesquels tabac il a cassé sauveur c'est
pas les gars c'est pas eu une maladresse
a suffi d'une fantaisie
ensuite quand je lui demande est amour
il m'a passé la salle hier ils étaient
souvent non papa il ne passe où il était
troublé faletau rui et bien et bien pour
qu'un jeune homme qui est avocat qui
part en public soit troublé à ce poids
il faut bien qu'ils viendraient sont
déjà présentes et qui t'aime ou papa si
cela était devenu n'y est pas alors ça
dépend
suivent yanez opérations des soldes avec
monsieur radu monsieur je sais tout
rapport les chrétiens d'amarrage à la
leçon pour ce pas la tête moi n'autorise
pas la tête d'hansson notamment conduit
thriller c'est pas toi donc qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
chez monsieur thibaudier est fini mais
permettez moi de vous adresser ce jules
frémissent à mon neveu dont je vous ai
parlé dans quelques mois
il est notre cher c sipa jarry bc olemps
bon de computation son rêve ne fait tout
était fini son rêve serait d'obtenir sa
main hors jeu devrait l'accompagner pour
traiter cette importante affaire mais je
suis retenu par une disposition
il se présentera seul à venir il suit
pas à pas non c'est impossible je ne
donnais pas parole à monsieur vient à
bout tu m'as balancé tu ton des
difficultés aux points soit 0,6
ouah ouah je vous soutiendrai on veut
que vous soutiendra mais qu'est ce que
tu veux que je fasse entre deux
prétendus vous considérez mais ce gars a
dit je comprends moi tu vois la mesure
pas bonjour cher beau père bonjour
bonjour mon fou sur le sécadou aubin
charmant de futurs vous êtes frêche ce
matin comme un bouquet de cerise
je vous remercie pour ma fraîcheur des
autres jours walt va trop loin
bonjour ni oui parfaitement je me suis
levé un peu tard peut-être avec le fait
est que vous l'aimez pas beaucoup la
campagne de matane - pas un reproche
assister au réveil de la nature je ne
connais pas de plus magnifique table les
fleurs ouvrent leur tennis le brin d'air
de redresse sa tête pour rendre hommage
au soleil levant le papillon et suisse
est elle encore humide des baisers de la
nuit la partie c'est comme bob l'abeille
diligente commence ses visites à la rose
tandis que la fourchette à tête noire
dans la journal
comment le journal tout l'a démontée
hier soir n ont perdu qu de l'iss pour
que la 1000 pardon monsieur thibaudier
c'est par inadvertance
y'a pas de mal je n'ai même pas lu vous
n'avez pas lu arcade et le monsieur
carayon je vous en prie je vous remercie
de vous appeler
j'aurais quand même bien voulu voir le
cours de la bourse aux boursiers casse
versée c'est la guerre de visite à
monsieur qui est là la grille à celui
des bombes ont tué chaque fois battu
dans l'autre
qu'est ce qu'on va faire je ne pouvais
pas il veut recruter d'autres encore
fallu après une visite à sabots perles
oubliées pâte à midi nous avons avery
pour les publications certainement
monsieur terradou certainement moins en
même le raccompagner monsieur garaad ou
volontiers maloisel wallon les fleurs
c'est que le soleil est bien en présence
mais quand même heure de sécheresse
alors regarder avec les yeux
s'ils pouvaient encore s'est cassé un
nombre à l'eau alors je vais arroser vos
fleurs mais pour les soins donnés zavos
à l'heure de vous j'attends ma
récompense
allons allons arrosé mousseurs vos
fleurs mosser rafale aux eau mais quelle
situation mais quelle situation
un prétendu accepté installés et un
autre un avocat encore il doit avoir une
langue fondamentaux retirer avec sa
langue sa jambe connaissent est capable
de lui dire oui comme à l'autre ça va en
faire deux circuits de vie dure ont déjà
fait mourir alors que je vais te jeu
mais bon je vais j'y vais j'y vais il
est charmant cette résistance et madame
il ya personne a tant mieux je redoutais
le plus c'était de rencontrer quelqu'un
je frissonne à l'idée me trouver en
présence de ce père qui sait que j'aime
sa fille ah oui je laime depuis ce dîner
où j'ai cassé un verre
je viens tous les jours à chatou pour
faire maintenant j'arrive par le convoi
de midi
j'ose pas rentrer je repars par suite de
une heure ça continue je vais prendre un
abonnement aux français
mais aujourd'hui j'ai eu le courage j'ai
franchi la grille sans attente dans la
brume accompagner je vais être obligé
tout seul moi même parce que ça se peut
est ce qu'il est possible de dire on
appelle monsieur j'aime votre fille
voulait voir la blessure de la donner
pour l'emmener chez moi et on peut pas
dire ces choses heures ça je n'oserais
jamais si je m'en allais personne ne m'a
vu je m'en vais je reviendrai demain à
midi trop tard mais s'ils achètent un
médecin oui monsieur ah oui mademoiselle
à quelle heure par hasard devant nous la
nar de votre dj aussi pâle s'est passé
bien le hasard en effet je passais chez
je cherchais le côté oui j'ai offert au
notaire de chatou j'ai vu une grille
j'ai sonné et c'est pas là mon père sera
charmé de pouvoir non non il ne le
dérangeait pas si je me retire pas vous
décevoir je suis pas fatiguée très jolie
s'écrier commandons si je vous jamais
paniqué et même si je ne craignais
d'être indiscret
puis je m'assieds vous demandez quoi
d'avoir la complaisance de me tenir pour
s'écrier avec bonheur avec transport
comme ça je sais bien je vous rends sans
peine des services là ce soir manche en
scène mardi
ce charmant sans gêne mardi déjà
si son père ne surprenait dans cette
position
il faut il faut pourtant je dise quelque
chose
il garde un oeil ou non jacques dessus
mais si china moses style je vous ai dit
appelant votre sucre habitants de tous
les six à non pas comme tous les sucres
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a dont j'étais trop
loin
mademoiselle cécile je vous est il de
canne ou de betterave
mais je ne sais pas je ne connais pas la
différence
enfin elle est très grande l'un est bien
plus ohlala
tandis que l'autre est récoltée par les
[ __ ] mais je vous remercie ses
bienfaits pourquoi ils me font rire dans
le caisson du sucre ou papa sébastien
ogier
il faut
je
[Musique]
c'est avec nous
certainement pas dans votre propos
certainement oui d'ailleurs important
jamais me fait garder en haleine
monsieur bonjour
pourquoi il m'offre un sucre vous allez
sans doute d'avancer je vous laisse du
temps rendez vous à toi
[Musique]
rage croyez qu'on m'appelait nous sommes
seuls
il a l'air d'avoir un aplomb de tous les
diables
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
guilhem segré jamais vous senti si mal à
mon aise c'est moi c'est lui
il va me faire sa demande mais récemment
reçu une lettre de ma tante
oui oui comme vatel cette chère dame et
comment va-t-elle pas parfaitement
autant mieux tant mieux
oh mon dieu je suis bien content
il aime très sucré sauf thermalisme qui
n'inquiète pas le buggy jours à ses
rhumatismes la quitte pas à tant mieux
tant mieux tomber
mais j'espère que le beau temps le
soleil le soleil mon paramètres montrent
le mien aussi
c'est drôle de baromètre qui monte en
même temps annoncé ses fâcheux pour mes
rosiers savall égayer vous êtes à matin
oui je suis passionné je fais des semis
aussi tant mieux tant mieux
jusque là ça va très bien il a l'air
bonhomme
si je l'essayé
monsieur oui il me dit mais coûte
monsieur oui dans sa lettre ma tante
n'aura pas pu m'accompagner
elle vous dénie vous annoncer ma visite
est en effet en effet nous y voilà
c'est aimer ne m'avait pas en les ppp
elle ne m'avait pas précisément indiqué
le but
comment il ne vous a pas dit nous ne m'a
pas soufflé mot juste encore plus
difficile oui monsieur
oui je suis là c'est en tremblant que je
viens solliciter
vous avez vu le soleil vous avez vu ce
soleil quel soleil sera tout brûlé dans
le coup avec des paillassons a beaucoup
beaucoup on a vu des progrès sont faits
oui monsieur
c'est en tremblant cnom et jonathan les
voulez vous voulu voulez-vous vous
rafraîchir merci je bois jamais entre mr
paris moi non plus deux familles une
fois qu'une fois j'avais très chaud ou
page
j'ai eu très soif alors j'ai voulu j'ai
pris moi heimberg be
j'ai voulu moi à merde j'ai voulu
marimbert de j'ai voulu moi j ai je vu
et ça m'a fait du mal tu sautes on y
attend
monsieur c'est en tremblant oui alors
vous cultiver les rosiers monsieur oui
j'expose l année dernière où les
tendeurs de ma radio de marengo oui moi
j'ai été j'ai exposé le géant des
batailles
je suis oui c'est un tremblement que je
viens solliciter en nous c'est vous
monsieur en uc vous remercie jamais à
travers près tout pour plaire mais dès
que je prise je vous en prie faites misé
plus je vous en prie monsieur c'est en
tremblant que je viens solliciter nasa
monsieur
c'est entre amp
que je viens solliciter la faveur au
lieu d obtenir
ouah mais quelques-unes de vos grèves
notamment des plaisirs jeune homme avec
très plaisir j'y vais tout de suite
monsieur oui non non mais je je je je
vais moi même les enveloppés dans de la
mousse mouillé il s'en va vous êtes il
vous dira va enchanter monsieur enchanté
ouf je l'échappée les dès maintenant
il est lui qui est parti et j'ai et je
veux trouver un mot imbéciles brut
elle vous avez causé réponse est oui
monsieur oui mademoiselle regretté
contentera en chanter est la preuve
si tu devais chercher ce que je demande
et non pas vous des grèves de rosiers
bref oui mademoiselle pendant un quart
d'heure c'est à ne pas y croire
nous n'avons parlé que du géant des
batailles et du triomphe de la branche
n'est pas prêt cela parce que parce que
je suis posté d'une infirmité plus
pleura ben je suis timide
vous aussi mais timide jusqu'à lidge
autisme jusqu'à l'agressivité si on ne
tueraient plutôt que de faire dire tout
haut ce que je pense tout bas depuis
trois mois c'est à dire que je vous aime
je vous adore vous êtes un ange mais il
me sembla qu'elle voulait dit très bien
ce à quoi ça m'a échappé je dirais plus
jamais je vous jure je ne demande pas de
serment qui me d'un avocat mais ça doit
bien fusionner pour plaider aussi je
plaide jamais ça m'est arrivé une fois
mais ça m'arrivera plus écouté ma tante
n'ont pas pu accompagner ma tante may
est procuré un client car dieu m'est
témoin je n'ai pas été recherchée c'est
peut-être un homme violent
il avait laissé tomber sa 15e d'autres
sa femme et vous le défendez vous allez
voir comme j'ai vendu le grand jour
arrive tous mes camarades et étale
l'audience et apparaît une plaidoirie
brillante saas avec parker alors le
président se lève et me dit on adresse
un geste bienveillant avocat vous avez
la parole alors je me lève je veux
parler est impossible
pas un son pas un mot alors le tribunal
il me regarda le président nous répéter
avocat vous avez la parole et je l'avais
pas du tout mon client me criait à
l'aide on a les dents alors je fais un
effort et quelque chose d'inhabituel et
sort de mon gosier
messieurs je vois comment le prévenu à
toutes ces vérités du tribunal et je
retombe sur nos pattes clients il a été
condamné au maximum 6 mois de prison
c'était trop peu pour cela est fait
souffrir ou si je n'ai pas voulu
recevoir d'honoraires il est vrai que
kim en occupant n'a pas offert mais
maintenant que vous me connaissez
voyez s'il m'est possible d'adresser
moi-même à monsieur votre père ne
demande mais je ne suis pourtant pas lui
demander mama pour vos annonces ne serai
pas content non eh ben je t'attendrai
que matin qu'il n'a pas pu vous
accompagne et vous le savez elle est le
seul que ma tante elle soit guéri à
temps droit mais vous ne savez donc pas
qu'il ya ici à notre prétendre outre
installé accueillis par mon père oh mon
dieu
une lutte qui arriva mais je n'aime pas
et c'est là on va faire ça les cous et
je mourrai certainement de chagrin
mourir vous où est votre pire tu viens
vous parler avait oui je parlerai
envoyer moins fou-fou tropez
oui oui je pense
je ferai pas j'ai un autre moyen
meilleur je vais écrire c'est ça le let
au moins nous net ne rougit pas ne
tremble pas on peut casser les vitres et
je les casses l'adresse à monsieur dit
baudier un tap
oui
voilà ce que ça oui déjà
photo me paul ii 7 ans ont la main sur
la partie monsieur vos grèves sont
prêtes
merci il n'a pas vu sa fille oui j'ai
fait a ajouté au rhône upe et l'épée je
fais ajouté au paquet lait les
commissaires et oise mille fois trop bon
tous ont répondu
pardon si on attend d'eux
les teen
il indique qu'en garçons le lettre sur
la pendule je reviendrai chercher la
réponse
[Musique]
il lève sur la pendue aux lettres sur la
pendule je me cherche partout et bien et
ne souhaiterait me sentais bien il vient
de sortir l'instant mais il paraît
qu'ils game écrit sur la pendule qui lui
tient tête à mono monsieur type odier
trop cher at il a mis un timbre en tarif
ne t'énerve pas vaillant petit on nous
serine bon voila il te dit j'aime
elle me dit à moitié prix j'aime votre
fille non je n'aime pas je l'adorent
n'écoute pas ses habitudes éloigné de
tout d'après compter ces choses ne vont
pas d'acheteurs tous avaient alors ces
différents jeux l'adorent et comment
qu'il savait mais qu'est ce qui te l'a
dit mais il me l'a dit a bâti ses
différentes
je l'aide quand boston et dans mes notes
apparaîtrait impertinence qui te dis le
à la suite ma passion il a su oui je
l'aide nous n'avez vous n'avez que deux
choses à mon free sa main ou une place à
charron tôt il viendra pas et depuis ce
qui me laisse le choix je vois pas
champions
non ne cherchez pas m'attendais à cette
je ne vous aime pas tant que ça vous
n'aimez pas votre effet si vous ne
voulez pas son bonheur je n'ai droit
qu'à votre aubaine pour tout l'amour que
j'ai pour vous et l anti mais qui tu
veux que je dise à monsieur corps où je
comprends votre ati me dit comment 128
militaires comme je suis pas timide moi
mais je pas peur dans ce cas radio mais
pas peur du tout je serai bien lui dire
ça me gênait que tu es triste quand je
lui dis laissez la langue ou simplement
boire
les sept tomes 7 rémy c'est quoi ne
parlez pas écrivait détruire messi
s'agit de décrire ça alors c'est pas
difficile on va te vas voir ça je vais
être terrible à tant monsieur est
peut-être un peu sec
non cher monsieur garde à vue car abu
garda broc car monsieur besson
bon après tout ce que tu me traites moi
votre recherche meubles à votre
recherche me flatte emana est mort mais
ils mettent à maxime ni de donner de
suite mis un beau projet de mariage avec
là avec ma fille du dance c'est pas tout
ça il faut donner une raison mais j'en
ai huit sabayon croyez bien chez
monsieur voyez bien cher monsieur que je
n'obéis en cette circonstance et recolle
même qu'à des considérations toute
particulière toute personnelle et qu'il
n'affaiblisse en rien les sentiments
avec lesquels j'ai l'honneur des abords
vois pas ce que tu appelles ça ne reste
aux toilettes
le voilà le voilà je voulais c'est quoi
tu t'envoles chargera de remettre votre
lettre
oui oui c'est juste lé plein d'idées
mais un petit peu comme vous l'aimez
d'action en fin d'année rappelons à m
moi mon père voulait pas encore prêt
sipa net
c'est paul bret pour pas faire pour
aller à la mairie de peu chez vous
certainement simplement bon si cette
dette la dette était venu mon gendre non
non cher monsieur sûr je me j'étais là
je ne savais pas quoi faire alors je me
suis permis de détruire une lettre qu'il
mérite sur la pendule les messieurs
d'un tic et sur la pendule quoi il
accorda il vient d'arriver
taito rebull cas corbel corbeille de
noces
vous avez acheté aurez vous verrez je
crois que ça n'est pas mal du tout il ya
surtout deux bracelets diable me suis
encore cassé un ongle barroso style
renaissance bleu sur fond d'or plein
surtout comment monsieur oui j'ai aussi
pensé à vous pas pâti boudier 1 - un
souvenir une tabatière comment monsieur
louis 200 restauration comment monsieur
non bonjour mesdames il aboutit à cher
papa thibout dit je vous aime bien moi
les eaunois aussi en inde un petit bout
d'homme d'état batié mondial-2010
dépêchons-nous votre mère va nous attend
la mer et bien pas ma mère monsieur le
maire va nous attendre à vis à vis
monsieur le maire oui je vais passer une
cravate rayée mois la vie je suis à bout
en cinq minutes y'a pas moyen de faire
autrement
tant mieux il a acheté lacordaire tant
pis je vais déchirer ma lettre
mon dieu une autre famille ça qui va
revenir chercher sa réponse temps quel
embarras mon ultime combat grâce à la
pas de nom mallette et non plus n'a pas
de nous mais il est celui de famille
seules oui ben ma fille ne pas pas
l'épousé de il a acheté la corbeille
alors bon alors à monsieur frémissent un
avocat au barreau de paris
maintenant mes toiles
sur la tendu sur la porte ouest par où
je sais moi sur la podium
ce sous la peau du lse la commune c'est
une laiterie sur la pendule une lettre s
qui n'auraient pas lu mal être pas si
c'est sa réponse sur notre boîte aux
lettres la pendule tiens c'est c'est bon
teint
je suis ému je n'ose pas lui offrir cher
monsieur ouattara cherche me flatte emon
ah qu'il est bon mais il est impossible
de donner suite à vos projets de mariage
avec ma fille ah qu'il est beau jeu
semblait déçu c'est sûr vous avez autant
plaire ou demoiselles et voici sa
réponse à monsieur jules famille saint
lô avocat au barreau de paris avec mon
temps et c'est lui qui me l'a remis sur
la boîte aux lettres sur la bande ou pas
c'est rohff la main d'un camarade tu
souhaites amène à fort vous chaque
risque que nous allons voir je ne suis
pas timide loi monsieur gisèle ah oui il
m'a changé une bâtisse une voiture volée
du lait pour qui tout de suite me pose
est celle d'énergie
comme ça que mon père ce judas ses
promesses
mon cher petit père j'ai du caractère
ankara tous les dossiers doivent payer
j'ai vu battre laval où vas-tu cécile je
pars je vous quitte mais où vas tu ne
jetez pas couvert et humide et 3 à
couvrir la coupole mais des points
toi pourquoi puisque vous n'avez pas la
force d'aimer votre fille de la délivrer
d'un prétendu qu'elle détaille c'est
impossible il a acheté la corbeille et
regarde maïmat ce témoin une tabatière 8
15 16 17 après je ne sais plus il n'y a
pas de restauration en tout cas assez
nous activer votre enfant une tabatière
à dieu mais non je ne te sacrifies pan
michard mensonge au nord et puis c'est
trop tard il passe un avis pour aller à
la mairie alors m'a dit rick a préféré
la compéti comment soit vous êtes mamane
malam alan malawi mal d'amour ce serait
un moyen et il vient de kia ca minutes
est ce que ça fait un éblouissement
risque à donf ya un éblouissement
annette affaires de sucre et remettez ça
je vais bien maintenant robe de chambre
mais ça je ne veux je prends un test
quand une pareille comédie notre marge
le pro bowl
je te préviens je dirai pas un mot moi
je veux mettre dernière a laissé connu
asseyez-vous annette tabouret là je
l'entends va les appeler mon père me
voilà près partout au monde yeux de quoi
aller plus mal et il s'en va tout à fait
impossible de sortir aujourd'hui
je proteste par mon silence pauvre
monsieur thibaudier il faudrait
peut-être vu appliquer quelques cents
supplémentaires
j'ai pas trop quoi il faut pas jouer
avec sa santé enfin voyons la santé
c'est comme la fortune on apprécie
réellement que lorsqu'on l'a perdu
m regardez le travail et il serait
bientôt rétablie achats est-ce qu'on va
passer tout a changé ici je commence à
avoir chaud sous cette manie l'humour la
disposition de mon père pour tirer
quelques jours mais si par exemple
écouter monsieur thibaudier quand il est
souffrant jamais un excellent jeune
homme du reste cette indisposition ne
retardera pas notre mariage le plus est
les seuls à la mairie enfin voyons la
présence de monsieur thibout dit n'est
pas nécessaire l'autorisation écrite
suffit d'une simple signature
veuillez signé je vois bien signé mais
il n'y a pas de sucre il n'y a pas deux
où est donc passée l'encrier
mademoiselle cécile à la bonté de le
tenir
merci ma fille remercie tout est perdu
la voiture et à l'écrit telle voiture
monsieur de radoub chapka manquons qui
se connaissent et oui j'ai eu l'honneur
de défendre monsieur c'est mon premier
client
c'est ma maison j'ai pas de prison
j'avais fait de la prison où une
querelle un moment de vivacité ya laissé
tomber sa canne sa première femme
c'était une petite bâtisse pourquoi
suffit pas à frapper une femme
retirez vous monsieur je reprenais la
corbeille non pas dans césar pour un
poignet votre tabatière monsieur mais
pas celle là monsieur a tout de même
parce que l'été
elle et moi ne me prenez votre place
je ne frise pas sur ta ballard de six
mois monsieur que ce petit incident vous
est rendu la santé j'ai bien une rb6 que
maintenant faites votre demande
mettez vos gants mais c'est une et ont
pas peur il est plus timide que vous il
faut faire sa demande
mettez vos gants pendant mais ce que je
n'ai pas peur il est plus timide que
vous un irish timide
[Musique]
monsieur monsieur pour la deuxième fois
lui demande la main de votre fille m'a
demandé sur un ton monsieur le temps qui
me convient ces fiches toujours la corde
je l'abordé sur un ton qui me convient
qu'on vous demande pas d'aller taquiner
voilà ce que voulez vous dire à la fin
du second ne cassez pas mais vers voilà
je vais les faire goûter mon petit bug
encore vous monsieur chien pour le final
mais ça me fait différente
la confine à sa saison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un petit bip l'auront la vérité
seront plus jamais
tibi de monde dix foix à pleurer
de ces saletés
nous a rassurés
et
claire
[Musique]
des pièces que nous venons de jouer moi
vous et de eugène labiche
la musique originale et de edgar bichon
les échos sont de roger hart
les postulants venant de corps
allez patrick bourgeois
valentine ducret
manille le poulain
et francis perrin
[Musique]
la mise en scène et de chants les gie
les indés chic toujours le boulet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]